squid game with jacksepticeye
it's quick game time let's go
for everyone watching i have never ever
played roblox before i'm surprised he
said
everybody yes is doing this right now
and it's fascinating we gotta get that
win in squid game have you won yet of
course no you haven't of course
invite friends you're my only friend
jack there you go how do we have four
friend requests already
you're so charismatic
wait i have to download roblox
yeah
jack there you are they're here i'm
right in front of you no way
you're working
you're so cool
dude you're are you bald oh no it's a
hat excuse me
i thought it was a video it's my
japanese fedora how dare you get it get
it get it oh get in we got 40 seconds
dude you think kanye west is in this
lobby
why
do you think kesha is here
definitely
positively yes what else do you think
they do on their free spare time make
music
no like tick tocks nah god some of these
skins are horrifying uh uh maybe now
you'll get a thank you jacksepticeye is
it happening it's happening i'm gonna
get i'm gonna die on the first no no no
no no you got this just don't move okay
here we go here we go go go go go go go
keep going
right there you are there
yeah we got this we got this going we're
going to be rich man you're going down
oh
god oh
it's scary
oh someone died nice not us we're
winning they're legendary
hell yeah we're youtubers we're gamers
we know this
oh that was tight
we're so far ahead
[Music]
you never play this we're only kicking
those kids asses
yeah well i'm an adult
oh god i chickened out on that one
oh some dude kicked our asses though
[Music]
no
no no
we made it through the first round we're
gonna be rich let's go
i can't wait 23 billion won cookie park
so i didn't understand that there's
other shape when i play this i haven't
watched that i almost said anime yet uh
the showy
[Laughter]
so i was like how can you not draw a
circle are you kidding me
i got the star no jack i'm gonna die
wait what did i get i don't know what
flavor cookie did you get there's people
in my face i can't see anything okay i
think i think i will live but i hear a
lot of people die
star cookie so tasty
wait are we supposed to be doing
something yeah you're supposed to join a
cookie jack what are you doing
oh i can't see my
coat in the wall no
i couldn't see anything
oh my my okay you were my gumball or
whatever it's called
damn it are you still in it i'm still in
it but i'll rejoin because it was the
first round and you can't die on the
cookie part come on i was i was just
going to spectate you i want to team up
and kill all the children you know
in the overnight thing got it that's
what it's about that's the real reason i
invited
dude roblox is tight
it's a great game they must make so much
money off this thing i mean who would
spend money on this
dude he's naruto
yo they got teamers they're teaming
chloe and ellie oh that's so sweet
invited like two two kids just chloe
daily
destroy this yeah let's murder them
they're gonna
make them break their lap that's the
goal
all right here we go all right chloe and
ellie or whatever
nervous all right first game is easy if
you go on that you're a loser
did you write that
okay where are they
all right here yeah here they are here's
ellie
pushing me
stay away from everybody they're gonna
ruin you
get away from me
oh oh
[Music]
someone is literally named
did you die it's just scary
it is scary
the alien baby died
all right look at the sweaty ones left
oh nice
yeah get him out get him out
[Music]
i think i walked no
i didn't look like he walked
go for it let's go
oh dude you are close that was clutch
dude
how could i move with these giant
testicles damn
you wiggle forth i saw you
do you want to hear something exciting
chloe and ellie aren't here
oh no
we were going to team with them
that we're going to be
trying to
break their sugar cookies oh
god we gotta wait a minute for these
come on
just walk
no
all right well don't die this time is
cookie crumbling look i went for the
triangle it gave me a circle i couldn't
see anything don't pick does it let the
cookie pick you oh okay okay that's easy
yeah it is easy no one should die at
this part it's a kids game check okay i
got this i got the star flavor i got the
triangle wow that was real that was real
hard
at this part it's so funny
oh no who [ __ ] it died in front of me
[Applause]
all right all right now we get to team
up and murder murder the children okay
i'll be downstairs like selling kidneys
all right okay where are you i'm behind
you i'm behind you let's kill this here
kill thing one should we climb no no no
climbing okay maybe maybe climb here
here here kill thing one let's go hey
thing one one a team thing one wanna be
friend oh god
oh so nervous
oh this is scary at all this is not a
kid's game
may the strongest survive oh i have a
baseball bat kill her
kill her
i can't see
anything oh no
oh no what if i hit you
okay okay we're still like
i keep climbing the beds
kill her kill her
[Music]
oh no too many too many back off back
off
uh-oh let's go
one more one more clutch
get her
killer you're being chased you mean all
right that's all
[Music]
where'd it go
oh my god stop jumping
oh i think one got so much health back i
know it so sucks
so annoying
okay
he thinks he's safe
[Music]
he thinks he's safe
ah
so close
okay that's good though okay wait wait
let me load my auto clicker
okay okay okay we're good is this do we
just have to keep spamming click on
something yeah
let's just hope they don't have auto
clickers because then we're then click
you fools click i don't know if it's
clicking or not we're winning right no
we're losing we're about to die no we're
winning
you're on the opposite team jack no
my god
okay in three seconds let go three 364
this sucks i can't no you're going down
no team
thing
only some of you died that's so sad oh
my god this is real
no i'm sorry wait wait wait some of us
do yeah
okay i'll spectate you wait for me
this is too real i gotta survive for you
now i miss when i pee off somebody died
all right i'm not i'm not i'm not
jumping
all right
uh we're doing the glass bridge
[Music]
oh god you guys only have 30 seconds
my dumb ass would still miss the safe
place oh god we gotta go we gotta go we
gotta go mane go you're all gonna die
oh god oh god oh god
he's gone oh god oh god what is
happening
i felt what
leah
leah's dead to me that was the worst
thing all right i'm gonna respawn i have
30 bucks i'm spending money to beat
these kids oh that means i won but no
one else is here because no one else
spent money in this game
i did it i did it jack
can i get robux all right i'm just going
to leave this is dumb i won why is this
game fun it's so dumb i don't know right
by the time someone makes like a
full-fledged version of this it's gonna
be the meme's gonna be over oh yeah yeah
exactly
this is what this is peak right here
baby this is what you get i love that
it's roblox that pioneered it i mean who
else
i want to get some skins
i'll pay money i want to be someone from
fortnite i can buy uh casual colors i
can change i can change you
can change baseball bat color that's so
cool yeah that's good you can beat
people in red now
wow okay let me look at avatar shot the
fedora was free so there are some stuff
you can get like if you search irish
fedora maybe
for sure
everyone has that okay i added my
swedish flag i don't know if it shows up
but i just see a japanese flag still in
your
hat good for you
that's sad
i just love when people say they're pro
in games like bruh you're not okay oh i
got the swedish flag let's go represent
let's go
i wanna see swedish
[Music]
oh god i hope you get shot first oh
there you are why does he
i didn't realize you're wearing a cape
oh it's a flag i know you're jealous
jack it's okay it's okay you're just a
bigger target oh oh oh
oh oh oh stinky
oh no one okay
who's doing it who's gonna do it
yeah you're catching up someone just got
vanished
she moved come on in the sea
i call shenanigans
and you see yeah she's cheating
damn nail them
uh just to show how pro i am i'm gonna
change my avatar while i'm playing
so you can get alcohol
you're getting dunked on you're moving
me
you're totally moving me yeah i want you
to die no die fool no please
46. okay i'm plenty of time i can't move
i can't
no no
ah
stop stop it it's not funny man
[Music]
it's so irritating
dude ratman's here
[Laughter]
did i die
no i'm kidding oh my god that was so
close that was so close
let's go
they thought they had me but they didn't
super children oh god don't be umbrella
don't be on bro give me umbrella
anything but umbrella game let's go what
is it uh circle
star every time man i feel like kids are
like playing on their dad's think pad or
something they're like how do i
like how can you die at this come on ah
rip
it's somebody
i think they're just trying to do it
super fast
yeah guys you have 20 more seconds like
chill push them oh see if you can cover
their screen maybe if you stand on top
of it yeah you can it's so annoying
yeah do it now right am i you almost
killed me last time right on my what's a
triangle now huh
you know basically yeah
yeah yeah go back there yes he died
that's what you get [ __ ] wait
why didn't this guy die
there you go
okay
laura princess laura princess you want a
team who do we who do we pick who are we
getting well we gotta pretend that we
team with them first and then backstab
them oh hot wheels
he's pushing you dude he's the first to
die yeah yeah of course take his
kneecaps okay yeah you like he's like
the floor he's part of the team like
he's part of the team you like the floor
huh okay don't kill me don't attack him
right away okay i need to hide because
the start is the scariest okay there's
no one over this side i'm going over
here you better not backstab me
okay hot wheels just murders you in your
sleep
oh lord there you go oh he's he's coming
towards me
oh he's a liar stinker i can't hit her
he's swinging at me kill her she's afk
kill her ow
[Music]
did you just
did you j she's not an afk she's alive
get her
i'm afraid i'll kill you no no kill her
kill her kill her i can't attack it's
glitched it means i don't know i can't
swing dude she's fighting back
she's weak she's not as innocent as she
looks wait it's not working jack don't
die don't die she's killing you
i can't swing my stupid bad it doesn't
work and izzy's not killing me because
she thinks you're only the same team
no one's killing anybody everyone's just
hanging out
i mean i wish i could kill her but it
doesn't work
kill her kill
kill her
kill her kill her do it
no jack run run you have one help
damn it killer i
i can't believe innocent killed you all
right all right all right watching me
murder them in this game they killed me
i'm gonna kill it oh god i tap that i
tap that [ __ ] well you guys are winning
handling here we go there we go
oh yes
come on harry come on harry
thank god
come on wait why isn't he i don't know
he's he's too strong he's a chosen one
well done
he's on zero
yeah i feel real proud of that one
swedish strength what can i say yeah
hurry lived
you just have to go for it right now
all right
rip
rip
uh do you have like a pebble or
something i can throw throw your shoes
oh harry
okay bye my process of elimination
good luck with that oh he did
oh god
you guys are [ __ ] i think you're all
going to lose no we're killing it it's
just me and legend
there we go i won
now i just have to live
now i just have to live all right 50 50.
damn look at him go
oh my god i'm doing it i'm doing
[Music]
let's go
two seconds left let's go
holy crap do you just win now no i don't
know hey survive 90 seconds let's go
should i wait just to see what happens
i'm kind of curious did they forget to
like add an option that you can win
quick oh he left it's just you and me
now so tense wow i wonder what's gonna
happen
careful you don't like trip and fall
over and bang your head or something all
the vips got bored and
bored and left there are other versions
of this one maybe we should try those
yeah you still need marbles in the
actual squid game
okay here we go what's gonna happen
oh oh there is the marvel bit and i can
play it on my own if i want to
[Music]
we just no one ever makes it to the
marble bit oh wait is that just like you
win i don't know but let's do this one
again then so we can make it to the
marble day we're gonna win this one jack
i feel it i feel it my fingers dude how
many kids just come home from school and
play this all evening
yeah i wish i had this when i was
younger yeah what did you play when you
got home like metal gear solid machine
that's not bad oh my god it's stream
all right you'll see then i guess in
this face reveal face reveal that's
right i am dream by the way guys
that's what the mask is
what that's the song they hide it on
mine
all right
anyway
oh my god i'm dream it's been proven
it's on the top of your head
it's a metaphor
it's not even a man this game has no
class man it's just
a vomit of
different culture
roblox death sound
you forget it belongs in the game
sometimes
yes
except roblox let's go
let's go
all right let's push him because it
works take the one furthest back
yeah dream
there can only be one
god that's so annoying
he's not fighting back i think he's afk
no no he was moving i saw him he's
pretending
[Music]
oh no
see now you've tested us so you're just
going to get ganged up here yeah don't
test this get out no he's trying to win
he's trying to win kill him kill him not
on my watch no no no no no no no no no
no
no no get him seven seconds
oh god
oh god yes yes
that was better than winning let's go
[Laughter]
no it's a game like it's a game
all right where's my character moonwalk
umbrella cookie let's go oh i get star
every time don't break the cookie
ain't no breaking
yay i finish first i am the best yeah
finish your cookie
or someone just
gets shot yeah i stood at their cookie
and then bang
get this guy
what happened he just flew up
[Music]
was it so funny
someone gets shot in the kids game
team don't get killed don't be stupid
like me oh this guy oh god i'm going to
die oh god
oh no
bro i'm actually from action
i'm actually dying just what just run
just right he's gonna kill me
they're beating his ass now
now you use the jump
[Music]
it's not worth it
it's not worth it
[Music]
can i have money to respawn in roblox
hey of course my chance
are you actually allowed respect
you not respawn here but the next game
next game
we're good great good just survive see
this is why we spend so much time making
money on youtube let's just spend it oh
yeah yeah to get actual privileges
not adult privileges privileges over
children
roblox is a capitalist society
you can never escape capitalism what's
up mia oh god no
you're gonna gang up at me and kill me
come on three seconds okay i'm alive i
played myself that game sophie's about
to die no sophie kill sophie can i can i
kill her
survive sophie sweden will rise again
yeah sophie
please be on my team yeah okay okay okay
now we're gonna yeah we're gonna really
click okay
let's ruin some kids lives i wanna click
so fast it'll feel like i'm cheating are
we winning
yeah yeah we're winning um
actually it's kind of like half and half
i don't trust them
yeah yeah we got him we got him
okay
that's no problem
[Music]
oh god oh god oh wait wait an idiot come
on come on
are you guys even clicking we can get
them we can get some of them yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh god they're
1200. we haven't moved no we haven't
moved we haven't moved no
no one is out no one is out
everyone lives that means some of them
are cheating too wow
wow can't believe
okay you are a glass man you're the guy
who knows the tempered glass yeah but i
ain't going first
oh someone else know the strat nice
okay dude i'm still gonna fall in i feel
like that too
some people are ellie has no chill
ellie's playing this day and night jesus
christ
no i'm gonna block people oh okay most
people are out sorry
i don't know which one it is i got i got
it okay
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
does that mean ellie died i didn't see
it oh my god it's just me no it's like
the anime you have to kill someone so i
can justify killing you no no no no oh
your body is still here
no
no no no we just make it to marbles we
just go all the way to marvelous of
course see in squid game
if you just agree to not kill each other
you can make it to the end and split the
money oh yeah yeah we'll definitely uh
please not betray no no no no no i want
to do i want to do marvel my poor dead
body
so confused
i don't like how you're chasing me hey
you [ __ ] sorry sorry sorry sorry
sorry
sorry i can't respawn okay
if you die
you die
die
i know that you get bored too easily so
you have to like spice things up and i'm
gonna be the butt of that joke what do
you mean
what play games what do you mean explain
20 seconds i just have to outlive your
patience for 20 seconds
that's forever basically for myself
let's face it
you'll never get into here mid bone oh
[ __ ] he's got the mid bunk fine
boring that's so intense
it feels like it feels like circuit
training god damn it
survived oh yeah yeah yeah all right all
right
oh marble marble let's go wait so how
does this work i don't know i never made
it this far welcome to our next game
marbles bro we played an hour almost i
can't believe it it just hit me what the
[ __ ] okay even or odd okay fun okay so
it's literally yeah okay okay and we
don't actually bet the amount it just
picks for us four rounds make it through
all of them make it two i can win in
that uh maybe i'll uh
okay so i'll pick
even are we not are we going against
each other yeah
oh baby
wait who hey i don't
i think we're just betting marbles
against the system i think we're just
playing against the house oh what no it
says i have three marbles
i have four models next seven okay i'm
so confused yeah i think we're just
playing against nothing why is spiffy
still here yeah he just left
come on spiffy
okay let's go
okay i'm on eight i'm on five
no
oh
god
i want everyone except the first one
okay there we go
okay so you want literally all of them
good job you have more than zero more
than zero okay that was easy nice good
job let's go
we don't have to betray each other right
away nice oh do we have to fight at
night time again nah we don't have to
fight why is there so many night fights
we even seen the show
there's like two per court oh yeah
oh yeah paul and break my neck oh yeah
oh yeah
oh yeah
oh you'll never find
me like a shadow i disappear
he is a shadow you're right where did he
go where did he go
where did he how did he get there
no
he's cheating
i clicked my way hold up where are you
god damn it
whatever you'll never get me whenever i
leave
i got my body's still there so i don't
know what's going to happen now what was
after a marble game the actual squid
game right
i think we just have to push each other
out of the ring
okay that could be fun great way to end
the video yeah
that took half of my health
so that means i just have to hit you
once more huh i'm not saviour leave me
alone oh
oh
oh that was it oh
what would that means we're both winners
i don't like that i don't want to share
ah come on
fine we're both we're both winners
check out jack for epic videos check out
me for more epic videos as in plural not
implying that anyone's more or less
i stopped recording okay good
i have new merch represent.com super
happy about this so i think you guys
will like it check it out